i think they have to be reclaimed that i
think that's why i call it reclaim yeah
and
they have to be reclaimed it's 95
percent of academics are pretty hard
left
um in university and that's not cool you
can't have a good debate when
95 people agree with each other and
they've bought into even my old acting
school
has bought totally bought into critical
race theory and anti-racism and stuff
like that
but i thought it was excellent what
prince william said when he said
this family is not racist and that was a
deliberate little spike at his brother
and his sort of weird anti-racist
narcissist
crap from his puppet master wife you
know
does it feel to you guys like a lot of
this stuff has been
imported from the u.s that our bad ideas
or
the bad ideas that have taken root here
suddenly are exported all over the place
yeah i mean when you go to what the bbc
described as a
largely peaceful protest of the black
lives matter last summer there were
people walking around going hands up
don't shoot and i'm like
our police force isn't old they
literally don't have guns
we've imported this straight from
america which is a great honor to
america because you know we love
american trends and all that stuff but
this is one american trend i wish it
stayed behind but at least you get to
keep megan right
well apparently she's going to run for
president now that's that's the new meme
we're hearing and she'd win
oh she'd win wouldn't she where are we
gonna where are we gonna go
fiji fiji that's the spot yeah
that's yeah that's the spot so all right
so america is
importing this or exporting this stuff
you guys are are importing this stuff
um what's it gonna take is it is it okay
we can
take back london by by getting the sane
mayor like what what's the real move
to really reverse this thing well
there's an interesting thing that's
developed now so
a um there's a there's a constituency on
the
in the north of britain called the red
wall which was always held by the labour
party and it
totally fell down the friction and went
to the conservatives they lent
their votes to the conservatives some
constituencies hasn't hadn't voted
conservative for 100 years
and um today um one of the
labor weirdly why would it be the labor
guy who's been done for sexual
harassment and had to resign
in immediately it's weird that that's
always them too isn't it it's so bizarre
what's going on here it's almost like
they're the exact thing they accuse us
of
um so that he's had to stand down today
so there's now going to be a by-election
and it'll be very very interesting to
see what happens up there but ultimately
i think
if you can open up the dialogue and you
can say listen there's 70 million people
in this country
we're not all racists we're not and i
will stand up and say we're not
then you you it's you know these guys
have been doing this for decades haven't
they marching through our universities
not even my
my kids right my youngest son said to me
i'm sorry this is racist dad but mum is
a better cook than you
and i'm like what say what now
so they're man they're filling it in
their heads
like constantly when trump got ill um
well he didn't really get ill did he
really get covered but when
whatever two days he disappeared they
announced it in the school assembly
you know and then everyone started
cheering and it's like my little son was
like i didn't want to cheer i don't want
to cheer when someone's not very well
so they they're hammering it in the
educational establishment is really bad
i think what you have to do is they
march through the institution slowly
we'll march straight back in so do you
think the institutions are
are worth saving or would you say that
they should be just
rebuilt or or just totally new
institutions
i i think they have to be reclaimed that
i think that's why i call it reclaim
yeah and they have to be reclaimed it's
95 percent of academics are pretty hard
left
um in university and that's not cool you
can't have a good debate when
95 people agree with each other um
they've bought into even mild acting
school
has bought totally brought into critical
race theory and anti-racism and stuff
like that
but i thought it was excellent what
prince william said when he said
this family is not racist and that was a
deliberate little spike at his brother
and his sort of weird anti-racist
narcissist
crap from his puppet master wife you
know
what what's going on with that whole
situation that you know i
covered it for like two seconds on the
show i didn't watch the full open
interview it's not that
interesting to me honestly from an
american perspective we just have bigger
problems
at the moment um but but is megan gonna
like
take down the whole monarchy that's kind
of what it feels like like that she's
going to import
all of these horrible ideas and just
that this is a threat to everything i
don't think she will succeed
because i think there's a huge amount of
goodwill there like if you look at the
photos of that wedding particularly
where they're
you know there's so much goodwill i mean
you know we have princes and princesses
in this country right you're not gonna
hate your prince and princess
so there was so much good will but what
we cannot abide
is what she's done which she's trying to
to make her
she's a being political which you know
you shouldn't be doing as a royal
i think she's just taken control of a
very compassionate guy
and she's she's realized she's not going
to be the center of attention
so she's gone right well i don't want to
be in the royal family anymore and then
you know in true kind of vengeful
narcissist style she's gone um right i'm
gonna take them down so she's accused
all of them of being racist by not being
particular about what it is
and it's a very it's a very you know and
i know how powerful that insult is
because i
get called racist all the time and it
really affects you
you know especially if you've got a
heart you're like ow i was not expecting
to be called that
um so i think what will happen is the
royal family will just find a very cool
very calm way of going i know
stay over there how does the
media play into all of this because you
guys
are well known for your tabloid media
i've had the guardian call me racist and
far right and all of that
stuff so even though we've obviously
exported a lot of the bad ideas one of
the things that i think that you guys
have exported
is some of like the tabloid journalism
kind of stuff like it's now
everywhere here it's like basically
there's no difference between
the the national enquirer in the new
york times at this point
yeah former newspaper um yeah it's it's
very
it's it's very sad it's been
particularly sad over lockdown
because the government briefed the and
they're now finding redacted statements
within the
scientific advisory group that have been
saying we need to get the people
frightened and stuff like this
so the government have briefed the media
and the media have loved it they've then
set the whole population on fire and
fear and now
everyone is terrified and they can't
move so i think the media
are you know but it's free speech right
i'm like say what you want
man but just can we just have
more of the whole picture instead of
just this very
focused picture on on what we want to
what we want to attack and what is
you know relevant to to to your kind of
selling newspapers narrative
it's been bad but even piers morgan got
even by the crocodile yeah
how's piers doing right now after he
walked off the set
he was i was quite friendly with piers
and then um
we fell out over covid um so i've
i've been saying to that he's um now
that he's
realized because he jumps on bandwagons
as you know in america you know when
shapiro when shapiro just ate him for
breakfast
over there assault rifle stuff so he's
doing the same thing he's just
reinventing himself we got a new news
channel
opening up in the uk called gb news
which is run by andrew neil who's
probably one of the best journalists
we have in the country and hopefully
that'll bring a bit more balance into it
but they're already trying to get that
cancelled as well
yeah do you guys have like uh like who
are the british
voices that we should know that that we
don't know
like who else who else is putting you on
on the map right now
definitely andrew neal um the newspapers
that have not given in
to the woke agenda but some of them have
most of them have but the telegraph
newspaper hasn't really given him
the the times did this horrible
evisceration of jordan peterson
the other day and i was just like [ __ ]
you yeah you know
[ __ ] you i was so saying that was meant
to be a sort of centrist
moderate paper and they're just like
stab stab stab so
the telegraph the express which you know
if you'd said the express 10 years ago
or 15 years ago in the uk they would
have gone nazi
but now it's like a bastion of centrism
it's weird
it's weird what about because i know i
know what people will say
okay you guys are saying you're
downplaying racism
and what what about the real
uh people that actually are racist the
the real
far right people whatever whatever
influence those groups have first off do
they have any
real influence at this point because in
american context
there are no legit political
racist groups there just aren't that
isn't to say there aren't
racist people there are of course but
they have been marginalized
are you trying to say that the left
create imaginary bogeymen
i'm starting to think we think in a
similar way
um the yeah so the far right in england
um it does exist but i mean there's
probably a
there's not very many of them you know
it's not and they don't really have any
power no one listens to them you know
also having the best time ever because
seeing as everyone's a racist they're
just hiding in plain sight right
no i think i think the thing is
we we in this sort of new woke religion
that we've
found ourselves in and we're looking for
heaven heaven is
is a world of no racism which everyone
would like a world no racism but
unfortunately
human beings are fallen and not people
they have to kill an awful lot of
indulgation yeah you're going to find
that there are going to be some actual
racists and what you want to do is
educate their children
that's all you want to do you know
you've got a nasty racist dude what are
you going to try and convince him of
but his kid you can educate and
hopefully
his child can turn out not to be racist
you know but we've done
i'm so i mean i'm brazenly patriotic
about
this country i think we're amazing and i
think you know america has kind of
fallen
for the next four years we'll see what
happens china is powerful actually
you've got
really i love the fact that you get your
own um
soldiers get their get to choose the
color of their own um combat gear now
that sounds
yes yes china's sticking their traps at
the moment
china's just going this is great um and
we've got
so i think england needs we need to look
at england and go what do you guys think
and i think you need to go well we
believe that we must stand freely
together i mean and we see all men and
women
unequal under the law i mean what's so
complicated about that crap
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell